welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Rick and Morty season 4
episode 2 video the old man in the seat
all about Rick's special special Zen
place I'm doing Easter Egg videos for
all the episodes this season if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get everything we do a merge giveaway
every week - I'll name a new winner at
the end of this obviously careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet will do top 10 WTF and
Easter eggs as we go along starting with
number 10 meat glooty Rick's new intern
played by Taika Waititi from thor
ragnarok Fame we open with the breakfast
scene as he introduces glooty the
writers said that Rick basically wanted
a slave somebody he could order to do
all these menial tasks that he doesn't
want to do anymore normally that would
be Morty but because of the new family
power dynamic in season 4 he can't ask
Morty to do all that stuff anymore so
they introduced the concept that Rick
totally knows about this dangerous app
that glooty wants to develop because of
his species wanting Earth's water and it
being their secret takeover plan but
he's too lazy to tell them which Morty
almost breaks the fourth wall when he
references later in the episode
Rick was too lazy to tell us about this
big plan that we should have avoided the
writers also explained that glooty was
created later in the process of making
the episode they created the high intern
first played by Sam Neill you probably
recognized his voice
also from thor ragnarok as the fake
version of odin just a coincidence that
he also happened to be in thor ragnarok
with Taika Waititi they created his
character first and they needed a bunch
of minions around him and glooty was one
of those characters or the characters
that became glooty so then they turned
him into a much bigger thing in cast ty
kawauti deism rick breaks the fourth
wall again when he says he's going on a
solo adventure this time this one not
being directed by Ron Howard some of
them gives away his secret that he's
actually going to a special Oh ASA swear
he takes dumps by himself they burn Ron
Howard again when Jerry says he would be
happy to have Ron Howard involved in his
dumps the writer of the episode Michael
Waldron actually said that he based this
storyline Rick going to the secret
dumper based on his real-life experience
in the Rick and Morty offices or at
least in the old office that they used
to have
apparently a lot of the writers on staff
have secret phobias of public toilets
but number 9 Rick's secret Zen planet of
isolation they actually called the
planet Omega 2 just a special oasis of
solitude very huge change from the
normal chaos that you would find Rickon
so the writers the animators said
everything about this planet was meant
to show this other side of Rick that
we'd never seen before and all this
secret tech that he'd been working on
that we hadn't seen yet but the title of
the episode the old man in the seat is
obviously a reference to Ernest
Hemingway's the old man in the sea
but in the context that this episode is
meant to reference the special toilet
that he has the episode itself is mostly
about exploring Rick's self-imposed
isolation and then jeffrey wright who
was the other special guest actor
playing tony gives him that big speech
at the end where he talks about the
message of the episode although it's
kind of a downer ending for him just
like the unity episode was a really
downer ending number 8 jerry talks
himself into making the app because he's
a total idiot so he goes to talk to
glooty inside rick's bedroom which he's
repurposed as some sort of office space
now he's put his caught on the other
side of the room and replaced it with
the photocopier in the whiteboard no
idea what Rick would need a photocopier
for because if he can beam his
consciousness into other Rick's bodies
then why does he need paper to transmit
information really I think the reason is
just part of this big intern joke
running through the episode the whole
idea that everyone from glue DS race is
a different level of intern and
typically you see interns doing really
menial slave-like tasks number 7 Rick
versus the intruder so it kind of goes
into Terminator mode after he finds that
broken branch and you see him analyzing
everything going all Sherlock on it they
revealed that everything in this
environment is just like Beth's secret
place that he created for her he made
this entire planet there are robotic
animals everywhere he has a special
secret underground lair control room and
they said that this was also supposed to
feel very different from Rick's normal
inventions where normally his inventions
seem kind of haphazard like you look at
his spaceship it's very advanced highly
functional but it's cobbled together and
it looks kind of like a piece of junk
but because they were using this planet
to show a completely different side of
Rick they wanted this space to look like
Ilan must designed it super clean super
Zen hyper advanced design light
which but I love the idea that he just
Scrolls through all these dumps and
spends the rest of the episode carrying
around
Tony's dump to deliver to him when he
finally tracks him down but number 6 WTF
they make the app and they use summer
storyline is mostly a joke about how
people give away their lives to
algorithms and apps letting tech
companies make their choices for them
despite the fact that most of the apps
themselves are pretty terrible as
evidenced by all the matches that she
was with the other part of the story too
is that the alien race uses these apps
to take over planets but the reason why
they're taking over the planet is just
because they want their water which is a
bit of a joke on the 1983 V science
fiction series where a bunch of aliens
from Mars that look kind of humanoid are
made themselves look humanoid wanted to
steal all of Earth's water so summer and
most of the rest of Earth's populations
spend the next week with in the episode
trying to bone everyone that the app
tells them thir match for which is also
a parody of pretty much every dating app
ever I love the way they kind of ease
into the craziness though because he
gives this impassioned speech and it
actually starts out really nice but then
it just devolves into complete chaos
with a couple behind them the wife
leaving the husband sorry this isn't
working out the husband bailing for
another match and just leaving the baby
there just wondering what's going on the
dude at the counter even switches his
sexuality on the dime because the app
tells him that he's into dudes now there
are couple Easter eggs in the background
for restaurants that are apparently
pretty gross like this one says toe Fung
as in toe fungus and then this other
restaurant just says chick belly number
5 glooty takes them to the mothership
so Morty despite being the voice of
reason somehow thinks that smashing the
computer will destroy the app Morty is
smarter than Jerry but he's still not
that smart himself they turned it into a
big full Morty Jerry adventure just like
when they went to Pluto together it's a
similar dynamic Jerry is an idiot and
then Morty spends the rest of the
episode trying to talk him down and fix
things you look in the background you
see a couple Easter eggs inside Jerry's
office there's a Titanic poster from the
Titanic episode the Gulf poster is from
the meeseeks and destroy' episode when
they tried to teach Jerry how to golf
and then the ominous beeping app is
actually a thing in real life in the
real world app store number 4 Rick's
quest for the rogue dumper they have
this joke about a mob boss played by Dan
Harmon who's a fly running
whole business for species that are
supposed to be his predators he's also a
dealer as he says many times he has
hundreds of thousands of children you
may have also detected the second big
celebrity cameo in the episode it's
Pamela add lawn
doing her Bobby hill voice from king of
the hill some of the animators on Rick
and Morty used to work on king of the
hill - so there's a bit of a connection
between those two shows so you kind of
have to picture a fly version of Bobby
hill buzzing around somewhere there's
another big joke about Rick creating
major villains for himself in this fly
organization like he doesn't kill them
after he left so they're gonna come
after him later
just like zip Zam floorp is still alive
down in the tiny verse they create this
whole giant intergalactic conflict but
Rick doesn't care about either of the
sides
it's sentient robots versus Crockett's
raised from The Vindicator zepa sewed
and in order to get that last piece is
implied that Rick destroyed most of the
Crocky bot army completely turning the
tide of the war even though he did not
care about either one of the sides I
wasn't sure how far they were gonna take
this motel scene during the episode
where summer tries to sleep with the
dude but it is implied that they
definitely did it so he's probably gonna
be arrested the day after this episode
happens but you start to see how
terrible the app actually is when she
starts to hate the dude who starts
snoring too loudly so she can't sleep
until it finds for another match and it
just continues on and on each new match
winds up being super terrible they do a
bit of a parody of the Graduate or any
wedding movie where she rushes to stop
her next match from getting married no
no no don't marry that person be with me
it erupts into chaos and a bunch of
people start flipping the genders that
they're into summer is now into women
she runs off with that woman and gets on
the plane but finds that she's disgusted
with her when she takes her shoes off
and starts picking through her toes on
the airplane Beth shows up and it
completely devolves into the airport
battle from Captain America Civil War
between the two of them as they fight
until glue dee saves the day throwing up
a paywall turns out all it takes to get
people to stop using dangerous apps is
to make them pay money for them but
number three Jerry Morty versus the
manag a trans as I said the height in
turn was played by Sam Neill they
created his character first during the
episode and then the rest of these other
little people around him the whole joke
about their race though is that he
spends this big villain monologue
explaining how they've mastered
committed relationships though
when they don't get their basic water
needs his own relationship crumbles with
his wife which is just the writers
saying that no one has truly figured out
perfect relationships and everybody is
kind of bad at it number two though Rick
versus the rogue dumper so you also
probably recognize this voice
- Jeffrey Wright from Westworld is doing
the voice of Tony he's also going to be
the voice of Marvel's watcher and their
what-if series is gonna debut during
2021 so he's all over the place they
kind of have a bonding moment over dead
wives because Rick's also lost his wife
even though it hasn't been confirmed
that she's dead we just know that she's
gone there's still a lot of theories
about what happened to Rick's wife they
revealed that Rick is really lonely and
doesn't actually want to kill Tony
despite leaving the most elaborate
middle finger device ever loved the
reveal of the giant Rick mech that he
uses to sit on Tony the animators in the
episode also said that Dan and Justin
spent a lot of time trying to figure out
the mechanics of how Rick's giant
mechanical butt would work and how they
would get Tony into this dream sequence
big surprise
Tony's fantasy is all about public
dumping and strap-ons so watch out for
that there's a bit of an easter egg for
the matrix when it's revealed that
they're all in those fluids sacks and
rick has just trapped a whole bunch of
people that he's caught previously
trying to use his dumper without his
permission but number one WTF Rick
finally decides he's going to let
someone close to him and be a friend and
in the post-credits scene so he decides
to accept Tony as his friend but he
winds up dying and then after that
elaborate sequence on the toilet with
the special crown they kind of end on a
downer moment as it seems like Rick is
never going to let someone get close to
him and it's a bit like the end of the
unity episode where he feels like he's
going to be alone for the rest of his
life they do drop a bit of a funny
Beverly Hills reference talking about
Texas tea trying to explain to the woman
why she shouldn't eat those laxative
chocolates and all that chili they
revealed that Beth was also using the
dating app secretly and almost ran away
to be with Ted Danson the post-credits
scene is also a bit of a funny Jerry tag
like Jerry's mind blowers Jerry goes for
a midnight snack and inside the fridge
we find the butter robot what is my
purpose
you notice the bully that Morty took out
in last week's episode is listed as
missing on the back of the milk carton
remember he was just floating away at
the end of that episode and it's
revealed that Jerry's fantasy is being a
simple water delivery man but the water
is actually called Mountain sweat so I
wouldn't drink any of that so let me
know in the comments if you spotted any
big easter eggs in the episode that i
didn't mention in the video i will do an
episode 3 trailer video in the next day
so look out for that congratulations
Benjamin Abruzzo you're the giveaway
winner from my last pic Rick and Morty
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 1 video and click
here for my Star Wars Mandalorian
episode 2 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]